what is going on YouTube ohhara here
welcome to my youtube channel and
welcome to my review of one piece
chapter one titled the dawn of adventure
in this series we are going to revisit
the beginnings of one piece so if you
haven't read the manga yet be careful
because there will be spoilers ahead I'm
looking forward to reliving the story
with you guys together and without
further view let's get right into it
we're starting off 22 years before the
main storyline we see a man kneeling in
front of two soldiers the swords crossed
in front of his chest
the man is gold Roger even though he's
on the verge of death
he doesn't look scared at all he grins
and says my treasure if you wanted you
can have it search for it I left
everything in the world
there the crowd around the plaza Cheers
and with those words the great pirate
era begins make a time skip and 22 years
later our story begins we see a small
port town it looks very peaceful there
windmills the sky is blue cows are
grazing on the fields and then the
harbor there lies a ship and it's pretty
clearly a pirate ship why is it a pirate
ship well you can see it's Jolly Roger
flapping in the wind the flag is a skull
with two swords crossed in its back and
over the left eye there are three
stripes why Luffy what are you doing
shouts one of the Pirates this is our
main hero of the story
monkey die Luffy he's a child from the
village and he's standing on top of the
ship with a knife in his hand and shouts
I'm not joking this time I've had enough
I'll prove it for you all to see it
seems like Luffy and the Pirates are
pretty good terms one of them shouts go
for it Luffy let's see what you're gonna
do again another one says I'm sure he's
gonna do something super funny again but
suddenly Luffy takes the knife and cuts
his cheek under his left eye the pirates
stare at him and go what Luffy cries out
in pain and they say idiot what the hell
are you doing we change locations a
little bit and are now in the bar inside
the village close to the port and the
pirates having a big feast they're all
drinking and feasting eating meat and
Luffy sits with the captain of the crew
who is introduced as red hair shanks
Luffy has a plaster over the wound under
his eye and like you can see tears in
his eyes and he's trying to prove that
it didn't hurt at all but Jenks calls
him out on that calls him a liar and
tells him never to do anything that
stupid again
but Luffy doesn't really care and tells
him well I'm not afraid of pain so take
me out to sea with you next time because
I want to be a pirate to Shang's laughs
at this and tell Luffy that he's not
ready to be a pirate yet especially cuz
can swim yet but Luffy tells them he
doesn't need to swim he'll just stay on
the boat and anyway he's a pretty good
fighter too and he shows shanks how he
trained his punch to be strong as a
pistol pistol Wow
really is all that Chang says to that
aloof is reaction to that is of course
what kind of tone is that supposed to be
and in the background all the other
pirates of the crew dance together drink
together and tell you fee how great the
pirate life is how awesome it is to be
out on the sea how free you are as a
pirate and Luffy is completely taken by
that idea and shanks only asks this
crude not to give him any stupid ideas
but they say well boss it's not that big
of a deal so why don't we just take him
with us for once and Shang says sure
like he can come with us if one of you
stays here in this place and they go
like well and I've said let's keep on
drinking and Luffy of course says what
kind of friends are you guys so that
also kind of shows the good relationship
Luffy has with the Pirates and shanks
basically explains that the reason he's
not taking Luffy is that he's basically
way too young to do it well if he tries
to convince him well Chang's I'm not a
kid anymore though and Shang says yeah
you're right don't be mad drink some
juice and handsome a glass of juice the
luffy of course takes empties in a sip
and shanks completely breaks out into
tears says well you really are a kid
like how funny you just drank the juice
to which Luffy replies what kind of
dirty trick is dad Luffy turns away cuz
he's a little mad now and one of the
part says Luffy you should try to
understand the captain's feelings
understanding people's feelings isn't
luffy's biggest strength so he asked
well how should I understand shanks
feelings and we see the person who's
actually talking to Luffy is been
Beckman who we like to find out is the
allegedly smartest person from the east
blue and he kind of tries to explain
Luffy a little bit the chance doesn't
really try to make fun of Luffy but more
off try Stu protect Luffy from doing
something risky and that the pirate life
definitely is dangerous as well but
Luffy kind of doesn't understand that
and Luffy just says well I think Jenks
just takes me for an idiot
turns around and sees shanks still
smirking at him saying can't even swim
and suddenly a young girl appears she's
introduced as Makino and she's the bar
owner
one of the villagers and a very
good-looking girl shanks immediately
starts grinning at her so I wonder why
the Pirates have been there for a year
but you you guys come to your own
conclusions there and she and she points
out that Cheng's looks very happy too
and the Luffy just says well why is he
happy though
and she asks Luffy if he wants anything
to eat and Luffy is totally up for that
is pretty hungry and offers Maki note to
pay the food with the treasure you'll
find and shanks kind of just says well
you don't have a treasure do you but
loopy says well he's gonna find it as a
pirate and then pay Makino back with it
and she seems to be fine with that is
really kind says sure I'll be waiting
for the treasure damn
so now shanks and Luffy are sitting
together eating steak and what I suppose
is egg or something different also
drinking sake of course shanks and Luffy
asks him well shanks how long you got
actually gonna stay here and shanks
kinda explains them well we've been here
for a year already and we kind of use
this as our base but now since we've
already been here so long we're just
gonna set sail a couple more times and
then probably gonna head north and go
somewhere else that Maki know looks a
little bit sad I would say so that's
another hint there and Luffy tells
shanks that he'll definitely learn how
to swim by them suddenly the door of the
bar is being stomped in and a group of
bandits enters the bar and they're
saying huh so this is what Pirates look
like Cobb is the first time I've ever
seen pirates they look kind of dumb to
me and in the bottom right panel we see
Luffy munching on a purple fruit which
might be important later on but we'll
see
right so the captain of the bandits who
we get to know as he guma start standing
next to shanks puts his head down and
tells Makino that he wants ten barrels
of sake for his bandits and Makino kind
of starts sweating a little bit and
tells them that she's sorry but that
there's no sake left and he guma kind of
turns around and asks well what are the
pirates drinking them is it water what
they're drinking like of course kind of
sarcastically but obviously Makino tells
well it is sake but it's it's all we
have left so he might have might have
figured that but sure what
my why not be passive-aggressive a
little bit and shanks is kind of polite
about it and excuses too - he guma about
not having any sake left but definitely
offers him the last bottle of sake as
kind of a say sorry gift and he guma
just looks at it and completely smashes
the bottle in shanks his face to which
the atmosphere in the room immediately
changes completely Makino is completely
shocked the bandits grin maliciously and
the Pirates just look very very coldly
at the scenery and Luffy still munching
on his fruit is completely shocked
waiting what's gonna happen next and he
gonna ask shanks who the hell he thinks
he's dealing with and that he shouldn't
take him so lightly but shanks kind of
ignores him looks kinda sadly at the
floor and says oh no now the floor is
all wet jicama just pulls out a wanted
poster of himself and says well we'll
look at this I'm a dangerous man I'm
worth 8 million berries and shanks still
kind of ignores him picks up the shards
and like says sorry - Tamaki no that
that the floor is all in a mess now -
Ichigo mah looks super pissed off that
he's been ignored pulls out his sword
and destroys everything that's on the
counter with a slash of his sword and he
looks down at shanks saying well it
looks like you're enjoying cleaning so
why don't you do it a little bit more
and takes his Bandit crew and leaves the
leaves the bar saying ah later your
chickens and what a pathetic sound this
is they don't even have such a let's
move on and luck you know immediately
like goes down to help shanks up asks
him are you all right captain did you
get hurt
which now I'm curious is that the
nickname they use in bed for each other
like captain open okay and shanks just
waves it off so it's not everything fine
exhales and then starts grinning and
suddenly this whole crew just starts
laughing completely breaking loose
laughing hard saying our captain looks
so silly back there and he got you
really good captain and Luffy just
stands there really not getting what's
happening right now
so guys at this point we're gonna make a
small break because the chapter is
actually over 50 pages long I am gonna
split it into two parts I hope you like
the contents so far if you have any
suggestions criticism or tips for
improvement please leave me a comment
below like the video if you like the
video and leave me dislike if you didn't
like it and otherwise I'm seeing it guys
next week